*imitation de Mickey* Ouais Pluto, nan pas dans la neige, pas dans la neige Pluto !
Ouais ouais je sais faire Mickey, c'est un truc qui est très peu utile
C'est parti pour une vidéo assez originale que personne n'a jamais fait sur YouTube
FAUX
En fait, même moi j'en ai déjà fait une.
Alors ça fait pas mal de temps que régulièrement vous m'envoyer des photos de personnes qui me ressemble.
Et c'est vrai que c'est souvent assez rigolo voire cocasses ce serait dommage de s'en priver donc let's go Michael Cera et Jesse Eisenberg
Ouai c'est vrai on se ressemble un peu, tout les trois on a un peu les même 3 trois acteurs
Bah comparons  un peu nos filmographie pour voir..
A bas tous d'un coup on se ressemble plus du tout tient. Alors là c'est assez troublant c'est la première fois qu'on me dit que je ressemble
à une grand mère qui prend le métro et qui visiblement écoute du gros son.
*HARD ROCK*
Bah écoutez madame on vous salue si vous n'êtes pas morte
Il ya un sosie à moi sportif qui revient souvent c'est
"Ronaldo" non non c'est pas Rolado, "Zidane" non c'est Florian Maurice qui s'en rappelle ?
C'est un joueur de l'équipe de Lyon
de la renaissance par contre ça choque que moi ce sourire le mec on dirait il est trop content de faire du foot quoi.
Et BUT !
Florian Maurice vous êtes viré du club de foot. Votre femme demande le divorce. Vous êtes mort.
évidemment Benjamin Pavard
ça fait plaisir le mec il totalement stylé ouais on a le même problème lui et moi
très souvent on nous compare physiquement à Jeff Tuche je laisse Benjamin répondre
Jeff Tuche, comment vous réagissait à ce surnom ?
*Pavard* Ben, écoutez c'est bien marrant au début mais au bout d'un moment
*Pavard* Mais au bout un moment
*Pavard* voilà c'est...
fdp
une question ouais John Smith de Mickey magazine
que pensez vous de votre ressemblance avec Norman fait des vidéos ? *Pavard* C'est une très très grande personne et j'ai beaucoup aussi
d'admiration pour lui c'est un battant c'est un vrai guerrier et c'est un vrai leader
Florian Maurice?! Nos lecteurs se demandent quel est votre ressenti par rapport à votre ressemblance avec Norman fait des vidéos ?
*Florian Maurice* J'adore le foot
Ah!
donc ce mec est censé me ressembler le style *le plus merdique de la voie lactée*
Je rigole merci pour la photo ça fait plaisir, voyont une autre photo pour voir
Le mec d'une photo à l'autre il est devenu ultra BG (beau gosse) quoi alors c'est vrai que mon visage ressemble beaucoup à cet acteur porno
même si c'est pas à cet endroit là que notre ressemblance est la plus frappante. **Méga beauf**
Alors je crois que je m'avance pas trop si je dis que ce sosie de moi
féminin est décédé cette personne est totalement flippante hein c'est la dame blanche
je me demande juste à quoi ressemble sa vie quoi
Les enfants maman a préparé une quiche
(Bruit flippant) Cris
Pourquoi ils font toujours ça et vous savez quoi, nikoumouk
il ya d'autres sosies de moi de l'époque
apparemment il est le mari de la meuf
il ya son amant et le fils c'est la famille addams, parfait.
Waouw, le flic de Narcos c'est d'ailleurs grâce à lui que j'ai commencé à faire ma petite moustache
et ça ça n'a pas marché moi ça faisait plutôt Cabrel. Ok donc nos yann c'est vraiment mon sosie turque *YANLIS*
ouais il ya une petite ressemblance ouais attend on peut zoomer un petit peu? Ah donc pour trouver sosie de moi ta tapper
blonds bouclés vomir yes d'accord donc sophie turner sort avec ce mec
ouais ça me regarde pas je suis pas qui est ce mec
mais j'ai un peu le sentiment qu'il est dans un moov un peu de comment dire
*Musique* J'suis dans la Friendzone *Musique*
Alors je sais pas qui est la personne qui m'a envoyé ça mais tu es peut-être daltonien c'est vrai que je ressemble à ce mec
c'est normal puisque c'est mon père quand il était jeune.
Ok donc ça c'est totalement mon sosie
sauf qu'il est beau voilà c'est moi en beau
Dégouttez
Mon cousin Russe 53 ans ok j'ai pas du tout envie de voir la photo
ah merde je l'ai ai vu c'est c'est bien moi
ouais c'est vrai que je ressemble pas mal à lui puisque
c'est moi en fait
Il ya ce mec qui fait partie d'un groupe de musique
comment s'appelle ce groupe d'ailleurs le groupe s'appelle les blancs moyens. Mon groupe de zik nan nan c'est pas les grands noirs c'est les blancs moyens
alors ce mec qui est totalement issus du moyen-âge et totalement la fusion entre moi et Eddy Depretto
Alors lui c'est une fusion entre moi
Maxime Muscat, Nekfeu mais métis et  roux en fait il me ressemble pas du tout
ah oui lui ressemble pas mal il s'agit de Jean Teulé qui est un romancier et auteur de bande dessinée
donc apparemment
quand je serais plus vieux je
ressemblerai sa yes j'ai hâte
Alors là non je ne suis pas d'accord le mec à 0 poil sur le torse alors que moi
Ouais moi si enfait.
Oh le petit Julien (LEGRANDJD) qui nous envoie un sosie de moi suisse. salam aleykoum
Alors sa on me le dit souvent c'est l'acteur du film "ça".
Alors lui par contre c'est ouf c'est juste mon profil c'est
Exactement ma tête quoi.
Ryan Gosling
c'est vrai que ça abusé là
la ressemblance et ouais c'est mon tweet c'est mon tweet.
J'ai beau avoir eu différents looks dans ma vie les gens me verront toujours de
la même manière c'est à dire un long tout maigre avec une grosse touffe sur la tête voilà un truc qui a bien souvent
Tahiti Bob même si avec le temps je ressemble quand même de plus en plus haut à Flanders.
Aller dernières célébrités et pas des moindres apparemment je ressemble à Justin Timberlake.
Ah non pas ce Justin,
Celui là celui qui avait aucun charisme ouais cool.
Et voici maintenant une peinture de mon ancêtre ,Sir fait des vidéos.
Excusez moi est ce que par hasard vous seriez pas mon ancêtre parce que je trouve que physiquement on se ressemble quand même beaucoup.
donc je me suis peut-être que ça se trouve c'est grâce à vous que sur terre donc.
*Ancêtre* Oui Norman je suis ton ancêtre, j'ai combattu des armées, j'ai fait tomber les empires à la simple force des mes bras pour que ma descendance
c'est à dire toi fasses des vidéo sur les toilettes et la raclette ???
ouais enfin j'ai quand même fait les barbecues les vendeurs...
ouais je retourne en 2018 hein.
Va si ferme ta gueule j'sais pas qui t'es quitter wesh.
Merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo mettait un petit pouce bleu euh cliquez sur la cloche pour recevoir mes notifications
Abonnez vous à ma chaîne et tout ça tout ça.
*Chtimi* hé Akim arrête de clèbe toi
Ci ci ci ci ciao.